wendy williams has a new man in her life
are you kidding me and despite the rumor
mill that's really all there is to it
for now we've got a lot to talk about
here's what we know there's chatter the
former talk show host and her new
boyfriend reportedly a new york city
police officer named henry tied the knot
but according to her manager it's not
true he tells et quote that's inaccurate
she is excited about a new relationship
and probably got carried away in
conversation wendy doesn't wish to
disclose details at the moment i feel
like everybody deserves
privacy right now wendy's manager says
her only priorities are her health and
launching her upcoming podcast they
don't know how to count me out her rep
goes on to hint at just how new this
relationship is saying quote you never
know anything is serious when it comes
to the affairs of the heart until it's
serious so how do we get there
it's weird doing hot topics and being a
hot topic you know what i mean it began
with a report from jason lee ceo of the
media outlet hollywood unlocked who also
happens to be good friends with wendy
jason later doubled down on his claim
amid denials from wendy's manager he
posted audio from his phone call with
wendy to instagram in which wendy
seemingly insists her manager is wrong
and she is married no everybody seems to
have a problem with that i'm married i'm
married i don't care who knows it i'm
married in a follow-up statement to e.t
wendy's manager says he never intended
to discredit jason that is weird to me
it should be noted wendy's walked down
the aisle twice before with her infamous
marriage to ex-manager kevin hunter
ending in divorce in 2019. i stuck with
um my ex-husband
because we had a son if we didn't have
children i would have been out you know
but we can't be surprised wendy hasn't
given up on finding mr right back in
june a source told et quote wendy wants
to fall in love and knows that's exactly
what she deserves and she told page six
this just a couple weeks ago
i want to
a lot of girls at 57 don't care about
excuse me
i'm gorgeous can i